guys we have one hour to beat minecraft
but everything is ten times bigger wait
why am i not
except for carl no the time already
started if we don't beat minecraft in
under an hour we have to dress as disney
princesses
and go on to walmart what oh my god
dibs on elsa and not only are all the
animals bigger but so are the mobs i'm
gonna try to get on this llama i know
who hit the llama who hit the llama oh
he's freaking out he's going haywire
oh it was the skelly no who killed him
ah
look at this giant sniper wait look at
jimmy
ah creeper these sacks are bigger than
carl
why is your pickaxe so big all right i'm
going to war
you have to go to war with a sword where
did you come from there's a traitor
ah chris your sword is huge
all right i'll work on slaughtering
animals wait i just thought of something
guys we should try to beat the game
big salmon big salmon fish on the water
look how cute he is hey chris can you
stop focusing so much on the big fish
and start focusing on winning the game
i don't want to be a disney princess i
definitely don't want that i forgot to
mention since i'm bigger
the tools are bigger they also mine a
bigger radius
chris watch out ah jimmy we have to beat
the game do you want to be a disney
princess
guys can i have cobble if jimmy would
let me get out of this giant hole
move jimmy stop let me place a block
ah can you give that pickaxe to him i
can't keep picking it up it's cause
you're so
large i'm demanding charge now
yo this is gonna be so easy to win the
game now we can just
dig oh oh my god i got nuked by a
creeper
guys i got an iron pickaxe hey let's go
and some torches
yo this shovel is
it takes nice much oh my god
it's so ob oh i found diamonds carl my
dumb
yeah baby there's no way we lose now oh
my god i'm a bedrock oh i'm at bedrock
too i have a problem i can't
jump and place a block i'm so tall sorry
jimmy we're over here getting diamonds
this is so
easy we're not gonna have to be disney
princesses oh i have to sneak
guys being tall sucks oh my inventory is
full of cobble
i'm free we're gonna keep getting
diamonds until the day we die
i have to dig down to use these furnaces
because i'm too far away
if it makes you feel better i'm having a
great time i'm glad you guys are having
fun i'm literally suffering shrimp
mining has never been so efficient
i say that and then plop some diamonds
right up in here we can build a base out
of diamonds carl yeah how are you doing
jimmy just mine and some iron with the
giant enderman the enderman looks like a
little toy
ah lava oh he's gonna kill me my boy got
a 25 stack you have 25 diamonds sorry 33
now
oh oh oh i found more diamonds
oh my god oh snap i just tear apart
trees when i walk by them your boy's got
11 diamonds hello there yo i can just
break into villagers homes what just
happened why is it dark
bro i'm about to mine like five obsidian
at the same exact time
i didn't think that through very well
here it is let's see it we're gonna get
all of the obsidian in one hit
this is the hardest thing i've ever done
in my entire life it fell in the lava
i hate this this is so hard to move
jimmy i'm coming up
oh my gosh oh my god look at that golem
let's do this
look at your giant shovel too he's gonna
come after you bro i ain't afraid of you
i can't hit him you're not even touching
him why did an enderman show up
oh it's taller than me oh that's so
terrifying
don't look at it in the eyes they don't
attack you oh my gosh
the end of pearl is massive that pickaxe
will never not be funny on you
chris's pickaxe is bigger than you ah my
pickaxe bigger
whoa you've got the biggest pickaxe
jimmy pickaxe boys
look at carl's little small pickaxe carl
has a tiny pickaxe
mine's proportionate gentlemen we have
37 minutes left to beat the game where
is our nether portal carl was in charge
of that oh yeah chris let's play
volleyball with the sheep
all right oh chris chris chris
oh stop chris turn around oh dear god
i'll go to war go to work oh thank god
sheep volleyball oh our volleyball died
salmon girl watch out giant zombie carl
the boys are coming oh god he's so large
we have to find
a lava pool the lava falls right here oh
i almost fell in it oh my god i was
about to say use your incredible sight
you giant
oh ah oh i like where your head's at
oh carl we did it make the portal i'm
confused do you guys want to be disney
princesses
we gotta go find water and find gravel
guys come on
all right carl i'm gonna light the
portal let's do it
let's go chris can you get in no we're
gonna have to make it taller for us
carl bye guys if me and chris tried to
go through this portal
nothing happens all right we can make it
bigger i'm going to get us more obsidian
i will do anything to find a bastion or
a fortress
why because you don't want to be a
disney princess oh
oh i found a bastion the second i said
that it's got to come to at least here
at least here all right light that light
that candle
yeah we did it hey carl i'm coming in
hot
what is this nether oh my god
oh my god yeah we're disney princesses
jimmy don't move
i can't leave i'm stuck this hurts my
head lead the way with your ginormous
sword i guess
this way let's do this thing that's so
wild it looks like you're flying across
it get hit by a backbone
get away you ugly thing oh ah
lava fell on me oh god please find a
fortress and get me some blaze rods
the zombie pigmen are going after me
they're giant swords
i need ender pearls so bad 15 minutes
remain
what i'm looking for some gold guys gold
i tell you
i'm still large and can't do anything i
can't move very well
what am i to do it's hard being a big
boy
i'm gonna have to be a disney princess
because i can't move my chunky minecraft
body around
oh the cast no it's so
large the nether is so terrifying why
they gotta make them bigger that makes
them scarier oh wait i think i found it
i found it okay guys i got the pearls ah
i'm too big to go through and there's
lava on top of it oh
giant magma cube has noticed me jimmy is
this what it's like being so freakishly
tall all the time
yes is this how shaq feels i'm going
crazy mode oh my god blazes are shooting
ah why is everything attacking me
oh my god there's so many things here to
kill me
and they're all freakishly large hey
chris where are you i found it
i'm trying so hard there's no chance i'm
a disney princess
that's okay i have fire resistance and
i'm here hey come to me
i see you oh my god i'm throwing a fire
resistance at you oh my god now there's
a gas
okay i just threw one oh god oh god my
inventory
i'm hitting the chug jug okay let's get
these blaze meisters
why is there a giant oh my god giant
blaze oh he's shooting giant bombs
oh another blaze rod under my belt
[Music]
the zombie pigmen are coming after me
five minutes gentlemen hold your horse
jimmy take the gold
take the gold i thought if you give them
gold they're nice
okay i have enough please rods chris
where are you every time i move
there's a thousand pigmen there what do
i okay you know what
kill me chris i have the eyes of ender
we can do this oh i got disconnected
no ready okay this direction this way
come on carl you're so slow hey carl
you guys go without me i'm cranking up
the heat we're doing this
go go go go we're doing this dream style
speed run go
yeah they can't even load the chunks as
fast as i'm running we're running faster
than the chugs
we're going to the end i don't care two
minutes speed run
believers okay i'm throwing another one
i'm too big i didn't see what direction
it went in let me crank it down a second
five
come on four through the jungle three
we can jump on trees one it doesn't
matter guys
sadly we did not beat minecraft in one
hour
no no we are now here at walmart i want
to go home
i don't know i guess to complete the
challenge we have to buy one thing so
let's buy some
green pineapple plastic is pineapple
green
uh did anyone bring their wallet no
stampede